so first a personal question because
I've watched a lot of cord's interviews
and he keeps talking about how when he
read eraser the book that the movie is
based on he felt like it was talking to
him like it was a book for him so I love
seeing that quality in films as well and
because I think this film is going to
have that effect on a lot of people out
there I am curious is there another
movie out there that's done that for you
where it felt like the movie or maybe
even a specific character was talking to
you I'd say the woman King
that was one of the first times that I
saw myself in a film unabashed when I
saw of course Violet Davis who I love
but the training sessions and being in
Africa all the different types of you
know short but the skin I I said that's
me I'm a woman King and I don't have to
apologize for it finally somebody sees
me like my people might have seen you
know Wonder Woman but I saw that and I
was like that's me that's such a good
answer I will keep talking about that
movie all day long because that one did
did not get the credit it deserved came
out it sure didn't all right so jumping
into this role now big broad question
what is something that stays consistent
in your prep process from film to film
roll to roll but then what is something
about Coraline that demanded something
different maybe something that you did
for the first time I'm always uh uh take
my script and I take pieces out of it
and I number it and I'm very strict
about that it's like something I do it's
not superstitious but it's just
something I do to prepare if I know what
the scenes are and that it sounds like a
very small thing
but um it's a big deal for me and uh for
Coraline that I don't do often or
haven't had to do often was remind
myself that I didn't have to do much in
this scene in order to be
successful I'm pulling back on my nature
because you've been I've been asked over
and over again to be this sort of
bombastic character or to be something
you know coming through the office
running things and I said you're a
strong woman coure knows that that's why
he hired you to stand next to to Jeffrey
Wright cuz you were going to be peers
but let him seduce you I don't think I'm
asked for people to seduce me and so I
had to ask myself what that looked like
and I had to go through my mind what
does seduction look like in classic
seduction cuz people say well you know
there's feminism and there's all that I
said no I'm going to throw all that away
I'm going to allow this man to see me
and I'll be available that's what I'll
be another beautiful example right there
I love that so much I Al love how her
profession kind of put her into Focus
for me so quickly at the beginning with
the specific line people are more than
their worst Deeds so can you tell us a
little bit about how her profession
influenced how you played her and maybe
the decision she makes throughout the
movie well you know this movie is
about AFF fiction false faces and I'll
just use this word passing you know he
asked her how can she uh you know as a
lawyer
um if someone's guilty still defend them
she knows that's her job but also she's
also admitting that she assumes a false
face as armor that's part of what this
movie is about the armor of who we are
so we can get to where we're going so we
can be successful but she knows she does
it and she thinks she does it for a good
cause she's not a she's not going to
judge whether they're good or bad she
says that's my job what he's going to do
next is a version of it to be
inauthentic to himself means that he
might cross over and be popular and
that's what he wants more than anything
I have a follow-up question to that but
I'm going to save it till the end
because it's a spoiler I'll go back to
uh working with Jeffrey now he's just
like absolutely exceptional you've had
many exceptional scene Partners over the
course of your career but what is
something about that the way that he
works as a scene partner that has made
him stand out I think that his wonderful
assumption is that
you know what you're
doing he doesn't have to do anything
extra he's certainly not trying to
instruct you so there's a very there's a
level of comfort that you have that he's
there you're there but you can also see
him working like he didn't just show up
he's working hard he's also working on
muscles that he doesn't get to do very
much you know everybody sort of trying
to assume how can I be in this scene not
how should I be but how can I be this
see somebody who's still at that level
working hard in a scene that looks
like oh it's just a scene about a man
and a woman or a brother and a brother
no it's not it's about so much more and
he wants to be Pitch Perfect so did I
but it was sort of a relief to say oh he
has to work too thank God I'm not the
only one this just you're my third
interview of the day today and it just
sounds like this was the most loving and
supportive set ever I keep hearing about
it over and over and that's that's what
we need in this industry and I think
that that quality shows on screen in the
finished product too oh good I mean it
was it was beautiful and yet you know
again there was nobody coddling anybody
we' had very little time and we had to
do our work and get down to it and I
think again you're looking at people C
Jefferson starts it off with the type of
script that he invites you to he invited
us to he asked me to play there was no
audition he asked me to have a
conversation with him that's beautiful
he is already assuming Erica you know
what you're doing let me tell you about
Cor line let me tell you what I'm trying
to build you know and then you go I want
to go somewhere where I'm
wanted I don't want to make the
Assumption I have to work so hard after
40 years now me 30 Years of Living
Single but 40 years in the business
somebody knows who I am knows that if I
say I can hit there I'mma pop it
there let's do it oh what a special
quality and experience so that's
something that happened with cord in the
the casting phase what about onset
working with him as an actor's director
cuz this it's his first feature he has
never directed actors before and I have
a feeling there's going to be many films
in his future what is something he did
for you as an actor's director that
you're excited for even more actors to
get to experience down the line he had
the courage to be anxious he wasn't sure
you could see it he wasn't trying to
hide and act like he knew everything he
knew he didn't know everything and he
knew he was Hing with a bunch of heavy
weights who knew more than him but no
one ever treated him like a first timer
we treated him and gave him the respect
that he deserved but he' also already
given us that so then it reciprocated we
saw him doing that thing and we let him
work those things out no one trying to
rescue him although you could see
Jeffrey and him working together you
know what I mean to to sort it out but
everybody let him do his thing it was
his good bad or ugly we were there with
him what a good answer to that question
um I get I got the one so I'm going to
go to my spoiler question so I'm going
to put up the spoiler warning for anyone
out there who hasn't seen American
fiction it is an absolute mustsee so
push pause go watch it then come back
and push PL starts right here all right
so of course I want to ask you about the
ending and also the the line that I
brought up earlier people are more than
their worst deed how do you think that
particular idea is going to affect her
after the events of the movie does that
mean that ultimately she will forgive
him for what happened I don't know if
she'll be able to because if you see the
movie and have seen the movie you'll see
that he is not
himself he changed she he's not the
person she met so she's not dealing with
the same person and she doesn't even
know how different he is they're having
an argument about a book that he won't
even admit he wrote she doesn't know who
he is anymore and I think as a person
who's Discerning and would start to get
to the truth cuz she's a lawyer that
would irritate her because she's a woman
who's gone through some things she's
gone through a divorce I think she's
looking for people to at least be
authentically honest about who they are
and he has not been and I I think that
that's a deal breaker he was so that at
the very beginning too yeah most perfect
audience because she met him before she
met him through his books so he's
attracted her to him but but she didn't
she didn't want that she wanted him she
actually read and liked the things that
nobody else was no no one liked jeez
yeah so that you could she's like a
party favor you could also get that gift
bag you can't have both now oh yeah spot
on answer that a lot of like really
spoton answers and really interesting
little nuggets there that caught me by
surprise I appr thank you that's for sh
experience with us I appreciate
it